[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique les
hôpitaux vont bénéficier d'un nouveau
plan de soutien du gouvernement agnès
buzyn devrait faire des annonces dans
les prochains jours reste à savoir
comment va s'articuler la réponse du
gouvernement
alors qu'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation aura lieu le 14 novembre
pour défendre l'accès à des soins de
qualité les personnels eux déplorent
toujours l'insécurité et réclament une
hausse de leurs salaires quel avenir et
quels moyens pour l'hôpital public
français peut-on éviter une déclaré
gradation de la qualité des soins et un
découragement des personnels souvent
surmené qui se sentent peu ou pas
considérer la france at-elle encore les
moyens de maintenir un véritable service
public de santé on en débat ce matin
avec nos invités didier martin bonjour
vous êtes député la république en marche
de côte-d'or vous est également médecin
de profession christophe avena bonjour
je vous êtes conseiller départemental ps
de côte-d'or vous êtes également vos six
médecins médecin urgentiste françois
thibault bonjour bonjour vous êtes
représentant de la cgt santé au chu de
dijon merci à tous les trois d'avoir
accepté cette invitation vous qui nous
regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission en direct sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dit
mme paul bourgogne alors françois
thibault j'ai envie de vous poser la
question le constat est assez rude
on a parlé sur cette antenne comme sur
dos depuis des mois même depuis des
années des services qui ferme dans le
rural des difficultés de l'hôpital
psychiatrique de la congestion de
service des urgences et du malaise
global de l'hôpital et c'est à vous
qu'il est pas médecin que j'ai envie de
dire est-ce que c'est grave docteur de
l'intérieur qu'est ce que vous en dites
oui je pense que c'est grave parce que
ce qu'on dit sur les urgences depuis
quelques mois maintenant en disant que
c'est le reflet de l'intérieur de
l'hôpital
on pourrait le dire par exemple de
chacun des hôpitaux qui est lui-même est
le reflet de l'ensemble du système de
santé public français aujourd'hui public
et quelquefois aussi en partie privées
ça veut dire que aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas comment remonter la pente parce que
ya pas si longtemps vous parlez des
urgences alors on va être mélangés dans
cette émission il n'y a pas que la
question des urgences il y en a d'autres
mais il ya déjà eu un chèque j'allais
dire de 750 millions d'euros qui a été
annoncé par agnès buzyn il n'y a pas si
longtemps
et malgré tout il ya encore 250 services
d'urgence qui sont en grève en moyenne
on à redéployer des crédits puisqu'il
n'y avait pas eu de vote budgétaire pour
débloquer ces 75 millions d'euros donc
c'est des crédits qu'on sait cdc des
crédits qu on redéploie et et
non j'étais resté sur les urgences et
qui finalement vous manque et ailleurs
nous ce qu'on souhaitait c'était que la
sur le vote de la loi de budgétaire
santé on est une réalité des chiffres
est la réalité des chiffres c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait être à 4 4%
d'augmentation du budget pour avoir la
continuité de ce qu'on a
la continuité de ce qu'on a et on est à
2,1 donc c'est vrai que ça paraît
contradictoire didier martin votre
majorité à la fois elle dit on va on va
faire un plan pour l'hôpital on met de
l'argent sur la table pour les urgences
en même temps quand on vote le budget de
la sécurité sociale c'est très timide
chaque année ce budget ses dépenses de
l'euro dames augmente certainement de
façon insuffisante parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de retard qui a été pris
l'hôpital souffre depuis longtemps
si on remonte un petit peu loin
depuis 35 heures qui n'ont jamais été
complètement compensé ensuite il ya eu
une première loi la loi de 2009 hôpital
santé patients t'avais patients santé
territoires qui a transformé les
hôpitaux en entreprise avec un chef
d'entreprise le directeur et qui
demandait sur l'activité une pression
intense sur l'activité de soins et puis
il ya eu la loi santé de madame touraine
2016 ça va toujours pas
2016 c'est pas si loin que cela il faut
encore et revenir sur la question de
l'hôpital les choses ne sont pas réglées
sauf que nous avons fait des avancées
pour les urgences des mesures à court
terme et demande des mesures à long
terme parce qu'il faut restructurer en
fait l'offre de soins on ne peut pas
traiter l'hôpital tout seul face aux
isolés même si c'est le pilier central
de notre système de soins
notre trésor national a dit madame but
un concert dans l'hôpital on ne peut pas
traiter que l'hôpital il faut traiter
toute l'offre de soin et l'organisation
entre la ville et l'hôpital christophe à
menacer quoi le problème à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui alors c'est l'hôpital qui
est malade vous l'avez dit vous avez
parlé des 750 millions d'euros qui avait
été mis sur la table alors faut préciser
d'abord que c'est sur trois ans bien sûr
que c'est pas du tout une de l'argent
qui a été redémarré ses distributions du
gic avait été anticipé en france mais on
a effectivement une enveloppe globale
elle qui n'augmentent pas de façon
suffisante alors c'est pas toujours
facile de comprendre pourquoi 2,1 ça ne
suffit pas la population augmente
la population vieillit la médecine fait
des progrès et il ya une inflation 2,1
ça veut dire que c'est la continuité
d'une ferme de nous encore fermé des
lits
ça veut dire que quand vous serez à même
ses progrès ça veut dire que la médecine
qui fait des progrès c'est une médecine
qui parfois plus cher bien sûr le fait
de pouvoir ferme le trésor je partage le
point de vue de la ministre de la santé
qui dit que c'est un trésor national
c'est même plus qu'un trésor c'est un
modèle social que la france à quelle
peut être dont elle peut et d'être
extrêmement fiers et dayan les français
sont je vous coupe mais les français
sont très attachés à la dirige réseau
ils ont hélas parce que c'est c'est
notre modèle social
et quand on veut le conserver vous
disiez en préalable moi je note je note
quand même que la situation est
extrêmement grave
vous l'avez dit en filigrane mais
aujourd'hui
malgré le dévouement sans faille et vous
l'avait bien dit des personnels qui
depuis toujours se sont dévoués à ce
métier auquel il croit à cet hôpital
qu'ils défendent aujourd'hui on a
atteint un point où la sécurité même des
patients peut être mis en cause il faut
donc prendre des mesures pour conserver
ce modesto qui a laissé un vrai problème
politique at on la volonté de conserver
ce modèle et y mettre les moyens
ou alors veut ton aller sur un autre
modèle d'autres modèles existent ne sont
pas les nôtres mais il existe une
question une équipe en soi thibault que
les moyens doivent être énorme et on a
l'impression qu'ils sont exponentielles
qu'il faut à chaque fois rajouter de
l'argent dans la machine et et
d'ailleurs est ce que c'est qu'une
question d'argent on pourra se poser la
question après c'est une question
d'argent parce que aujourd'hui on veut
faire rentrer les besoins du territoire
dans les enveloppes qu'on a décidé
depuis paris mais non pour moi c'est pas
forcément une question d'argent c'est
une question d'organisation du
territoire c'est à dire que on ne mesure
pas toujours les conséquences et les
coûts cachés d'une fermeture par exemple
d'une structure de proximité
aujourd'hui cet enseignement du gain les
économies aujourd'hui aucune étude ne
nous démontre qu'une maternité qui ne
fait pas beaucoup d'accueil
d'accouchement est une maternité
dangereuse par contre fermer cette
maternité là et puis envoyé 40 minutes
45 minutes par la route des femmes qui
vont accouché dans une maternité de
niveau ou de niveau iii pardon comme
dijon qui elle est déjà surchargé parce
que elle est la seule maternité
régionale de ce niveau là c'est ce n'est
pas rendre service à la patiente et
c'est éventuellement effectivement
plutôt la mettre en danger vous
dénonciez gauthier il ya quelques
minutes didier martha qu on voulait un
peu finalement à une époque gérer des
hôpitaux comme des entreprises
aujourd'hui on en est revenu de sa tout
à fait en particulier pour les urgences
on a commencé sur ce sur ce sujet des
urgences parce qu'il est hautement
symbolique
il y à l'engorgement des urgences le nom
et c'est pas d'envisager enfin beaucoup
mais oui mais en vingt ans on est passé
10 millions de l'admission à 21 et
quelques millions d'admission évidemment
on peut pas faire fonctionner un système
de santé le en particulier à nuire parce
que les week-ends sur une seule porte
il faut donc organiser comment peut-on
organiser alors il ya le jour il ya la
nuit va pas tout mélanger dans le projet
de loi va santé 2022 on met en place les
hôpitaux dits de proximité
ces hôpitaux de proximité ils ne vont
pas être rémunéré à l'activité comme on
voulait les poussées autrefois ils vont
être rémunérés sur un modèle original
avec un socle des lits de long séjour
des lits d'ehpad des lits de médecine
etc
et puis des activités je dirais
optionnel qui dépendra de l'activité
avec des spécialistes qui peuvent venir
d'un hôpital central avec des plateaux
techniques qui peuvent être modulés et
donc les un complément de rémunération
pour ces hôpitaux de proximité c'est à
travers les contrats professionnels
territoriaux de santé entre les
professionnels privés et publics
on va mettre en place ces structures là
ça commence aux cabinets des médecins et
dans les maisons de santé dans le nombre
est multiplié par quatre ou cinq de ces
maisons de santé parce que les
professionnels se regroupent dans tous
les territoires puis l'hôpital de
proximité avec un hôpital de référence
et une régulation très importante de
façon à ce que avec le 15 avec l'appel
aux pompiers parfois aussi et avec le
case principalement et est assez nerveux
médicale un numéro unique
que ce soit le jour que ce soit la nuit
on puisse effectivement avoir accès à
des soins d'urgence mais pas seulement
parce qu'aujourd'hui pour avoir un
rendez vous chez un spécialiste et même
chez un généraliste et parfois très
compliqué qui à travers moi j'ai une
question à qui s'adresse à monsieur
martin un des hôpitaux de proximité
j'ai lu avec détail les amendements les
concernant j'ai quelques inquiétudes à
ce sujet effectivement le maillage
territorial est important ma question et
en bourgogne par exemple quelles
seraient les hôpitaux identifiés comme
des hôpitaux de proximité
parce que ils dans leur structuration il
ne renie et obstétrique ni chirurgie
c'est ce qui a été définie dans ces
hôpitaux lent en bourgogne quels seront
les hôpitaux qui vont être identifié
comme tel c'est une vraie question
exactement c'est le travail qui s'ouvre
pour l'année 2020 c'est à dire que la rs
l'autorité de tutelle va avec les
professionnels de santé avec les
équipements les infrastructures définir
des missions de ces hôpitaux de
proximité
certains ont un scanner certains auront
un laboratoire de biologie
il n'y aura effectivement pas de
chirurgie générale mais il peut y avoir
des consultations spécialisées et donc
pour la chirurgie programmée
aucun problème en revanche pas ce qui
concerne l'urgence il faut effectivement
une prise en charge sur place un
diagnostic sur place voir assister avec
la télémédecine et l'assistance à
distance de façon à faire le bon
diagnostic pendant la bonne décision
pareille ça va prendre des années
d'organiser tout ça non non non ça va
peut prendre des années je moi je crois
moi je fais confiance aux professionnels
sap arena fallait de leurs valises il
encourage on a parlé de leur
professionnalisme
les professionnels de santé privés et
publics dans les territoires
ils connaissent les propos l'instant
vous ne voulez pas dire où seront ses
hôpitaux de proximité parce que moi vous
savez je suis un candidat et maintenant
avec la direction générale de l'hôpital
avec la direction de l'hôpital la
chartreuse parce que je suis dit je n'ai
avec monsieur pribyl et nous l'avons vu
encore cette semaine ses hôpitaux que ce
soit mon bar soit ce lieu que ce soit
gré que ce soit mme août que etc clamecy
ou à tous les hôpitaux sont amenés
tonnerre etc seront amenés à faire leurs
propositions et surtout ce qui le
critère nouveau qui sera pris en compte
c'est l'articulation entre la structure
hospitalière et la structure de ville ce
que dans certains cas il n'y aura hélas
que des médecins il a pas forcément et
là ce sera la chance de l'hôpital de
proximité d'être maintenue pour parce
qu'il dira que des médecins de ville
pour faire fonctionner le pisa de
fonction soit thibout quel est votre
votre regard sur cette réorganisation
finalement du système de santé du point
de départ c'est à dire du médecin de
ville ou de la maison de santé jusqu'à
l'hôpital de référence comme didier
martin moi je suis je suis toujours un
petit peu gêné de
de ce qu'on entend et de ce conte relais
c'est à dire que la médecine de ville
aujourd'hui
soit on est dans un territoire urbain
comme celui de dijon et je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait de problème
la gamme des gens qui arrivent à qui
arrive aux urgences parce qu'ils n'ont
pas eu de rendez vous chez leur médecin
elle fait son travail elle le fait du
mieux qu'elle peut et elle répond les
passages injustifiée aux urgences moi je
voudrais vraiment mettre un bémol là
dessus on parle 1re au niveau mondial je
crois qu'on est dans des pays équivalent
et développer on est à peu près à 20% de
passage injustifiée en moyenne aux
urgences en france suivant les études et
les critères comprend pour définir le le
passage injustifiée on peut tomber à 13
% voire même bien en dessous si on prend
tous les critères y compris la vie
d'urgentistes qui reçoit le patient il
faut prendre des critères qui sont des
critères objectifs et des critères
subjectifs le l'avis du médecin qui
reçoit le patient s'il voit un patient
dans une grande dans un grand état
d'anxiété et qui a besoin de réponses
c'est un passage justifiée aux urgences
c'est d'autant plus justifiée si
derrière on a un bilan sanguin on a
recours à une irm un scanner donc c'est
plutôt un sentiment on verra tout à
l'heure dans un sondage des français
pour souci qui a des passages
injustifiée alors aux urgences c'est
sympa mais alors les passages un suivi
aux urgences est vraiment un sujet très
intéressant je disais tout à l'heure que
le problème des urgences étaient le
symptôme d'une maladie bien plus g
le problème des urgences est pas le
passage injustifiée aux urgences les
médias où nous explique longuement que
l'on culpabilise un peu les gens qui
utilisent les urgences ni de façon
inappropriée la réalité est bien plus
terrible que ça aller aux urgences jus
c'est assez simple quelqu'un qui vient
aux gens pour rien si on ne s'en occupe
pas c'est pas grave puisqu'il est venu
pour rien comprenez médicalement parlant
il avait rien à y faire il va y rester
longtemps déjà pour qu'il reste
plusieurs heures c'est qu'ils avaient
largement service quand même nos ennemis
ont leurs prêts soit l'identité et vient
la viande et sa carte vitale et il ya
l'ambulance parfois qu'il a et bien non
ce qu'ils ont c'est du gaspillage ce qui
engorge les services sur les brancards
c'est les personnes qui ont quelque
chose à faire à l'hôpital pour lequel
nous n'avons plus de lits est
aujourd'hui le d'ailleurs le livre
personnel 6 il publie plus de personnels
plus de moyens plus de valorisation du
personnel si aujourd'hui le plan urgence
a été rejetée de la paix
des gens qui sont en règle partout en
france c'est parce que les
revendications principales
c'était surtout un moratoire sur la
fermeture des lits et une augmentation
de reconnaissance du personnel ces deux
cas et sans ces deux demandes
essentielles n'ont pas été suivies
d'effet
nous avons besoin de lits pour s'occuper
parce que c'est la fierté de l'hôpital
de s'occuper de tout le monde même des
personnes âgées bien au contraire et
d'être bien traitants et bienveillant
mais à partir du moment où vous avez des
personnes qui restent longtemps sur un
brancard site tout simplement parce que
le nombre de lui on a fermé un nombre de
lits considérable dans ce pays
d'ailleurs pas qu aux urgences et on a
fermé dans différents services plus de
4000 en 2018 c'est je crois sans sang
min
sur les dix dernières années en devient
donc effectivement mais vous le dites
pas qu aux urgences mais le problème des
urgences où on dit c'est le miroir de
l'hôpital mais le problème des urgences
et les lits fermés pas aux urgences et
des lits fermés dans la série c'est à
dire que une fois que vous avez
stabiliser votre patient et qu'il est
prêt à monter dans le service de sa
spécialité
là il faut lui trouver un lit quand
madame musée 1 propose et c'est ça qui
est gênant c'est c'est le côté vous
parlez d'hôpital sous perfusion dans le
titre c'est la perfusion elle est là
pour regonfler elle n'est pas là pour
soigner
c'est à dire qu'on fait remonter les
constantes héros dc mais qui a connu à
perfusion il ya pas pour l'instant les
annonces elle arrive un petit peu comme
des perfusions au contenu dans tous les
cas on était un peu au compte-gouttes
oui c'est à dire qu'il faut il faut
effectivement aller s'attaquer à la
racine est la racine c'est pas par
exemple l'infirmier de pratiques
avancées aux urgences qui va faire des
sutures ça sera utile qu'il va faire des
déçus du revers la profession est parce
que ça fait des années que les
infirmiers se bat pour la pratique de la
pratique avancée ne chante la chanson ne
changeons pas le
les choses si rapidement le médecin il
aura le temps de la faire sa future si
on le dispense de passer des heures au
téléphone dans la nuit pour chercher de
vaud avait raison donc il faut du temps
médical
donc il faut il faut pas transférer la
compétence et même le coeur du métier du
médecin vers des infirmiers et s'est
qualifiée soit il il faut il faut
permettre aux médecins d'exercer sont
pleinement son métier à l'intérieur de
son service donc il faut effectivement
le décharger de cette tâche qui est une
tâche administrative alors mais je
voudrais juste rajouter que le meilleur
des bleds manager il vous trouvera pas
de lit si on n'a pas ça va pas oui même
dans un hôtel c'est compliqué des fois
elle didier martin on attend les
annonces de daniel güiza dans les jours
qui viennent
on a quelques bribes on a bien compris
qu'il y aurait encore de l'argent versé
notamment pour l'achat de nouveau
matériel mais alors pour l'ouverture de
lits on n'en sait rien il faut
revaloriser les salaires dit lb c'est
pareil dans quelle mesure est ce que
vous vous avez déjà des éléments au sein
de la majorité la république en marche
sur ce que pourraient être les annonces
d'agnès busin dans quelques jours je
crois que ce plan il sera articulé sur
deux chapitres principaux d'une part les
investissements pour effectivement ces
maisons de santé pour effectivement ces
hôpitaux de proximité pour effectivement
une meilleure organisation et de la
télémédecine et puis il ya un plan très
important à mon sens de revalorisation
des carrières et de parcours
professionnel parce que l'épuisement
professionnel
on peut le comprendre dans un service
aussi intense que les urgences on en a
beaucoup parlé on n'a pas tout dit parce
qu'il ya un plan qui va venir aussi pour
les urgences bon que les ingénieurs car
les travaille sur ce plan là qui viendra
en complément et c'est beaucoup pas
seulement des lits je sais qu'on des
délits d les délits ça manque souvent
mais ce qui montre aussi c'est
l'organisation et je crois qu'il faut
insister sur ce nouveau oui il
semblerait que agnès buzyn vise
réorganisation aussi des services à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital et du
fonctionnement à l'intérieur une
admission directe en gériatrie par
exemple c'est un progrès une admission
directe pour une urgence ne laissant au
milieu pédopsychiatrique c'est un
progrès c'est un brillant il a
réorganisé notre qui dirait organisation
se dit aussi un peu flexibilité appris
ça parce que moi qui travaille en
régulation à chaque fois qu'on a
l'occasion et la possibilité de faire d
adressage direct dans les services on
essaye de le fermer ses services
n'accepte les médecins de ville
aujourd'hui n'ont pas d'autre
possibilité que d'adresser leurs
patients aux urgences pour qu'il soit
pris en compte à l'hôpital parce que les
lignes de l'hôpital les services ne
disposent pas de lits disponibles
c'est pas quelque chose de le fait de le
dire
vous savez quand on n'a pas l'argent on
réorganise on a beaucoup ri organisé on
réorganise on réorganise aujourd'hui la
question que vous avez posé en début
c'est peut-on at on les moyens d'avoir
un hôpital public dans ce pays je le
pense
on les a mais pour ça il faut mettre un
plan la hauteur des enjeux
les enjeux sont extrêmement importants
le plan doit être assez de hauteur et on
ne peut pas d'un côté avoir fait les
décisions sur les augmentations
budgétaires limitées à demain donc
globalement une perte de moyens et de
l'autre dire qu en réorganisant au
récupèrera cette activité ça n'est pas
suffisant
ça fait des années qu'on réorganise
cette organisation était bien mené
elle a été fait et aujourd'hui il faut
des moyens pour pouvoir accueillir nos
patients françois thibault le
découragement des personnels c'est un
autre problème on ne sait pas s'il est
lié à la question des financements en
tous les cas il ya certainement une
question de salaire puisque les
personnels demandent des hausses de
salaires mais est ce que c'est le seul
problème finalement est ce qui apparaît
manque de considération à l'épuisement
psychologique on peut quand même parler
juste du salaire pour situer les choses
aujourd'hui un smic net en france c'est
1171 euros une infirmière elle démarre
aujourd'hui à 1244 l'attrait trois ans
d'études après trois ans d'études dans
la fonction publique en est un pas parce
qu'on parle toujours en brut nous
plaisons toujours l'impression que c'est
vrai j'en gagne beaucoup d'argent
non on a dit ce qu'on a dans la poche à
la fin on est c'est ce qu'on a dans la
poche à la fin du mois et c'est ça donc
effectivement
je pense que ça mérite des
revalorisations qui sont des
revalorisation globale qui ne doivent
pas se faire service par service mais se
faire déjà dans un premier temps
globalement après sur la considération /
le bien-être au travail je vais
reprendre deux exemples que monsieur
martin nous a donné
l'admission direct de patients en
psychiatrie
eh bien il ya un établissement de
côte-d'or là sur lequel il y a eu
pendant neuf jours aux urgences donc sur
l'unité de courte durée un patient en
attente d'une place en psychiatrie
sachant que la psychiatrie est sectorisé
c'est à dire qu'on est effectivement
obligé de prendre ce patient là on
s'engage à le faire et on s'engage à le
soigner mais là on avait plus place donc
il est resté neuf jours dans un service
qui n'était pas adapté pour lui qui
était un service d'urgence la gériatrie
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
la gériatrie pourquoi aux urgences de
général systématiquement pourquoi pas
effectivement une porte spécialisé
urgences gériatriques
cet été nous avons fermé pendant tout
l'été un service gériatrique à
champmaillot faute de médecins nous
allons fermer ce service purement et
simplement nous allons leur ouvrir la
fin novembre
l'idée marta est ce qu il yad autres
annoncent qu agnès buzyn pourrait faire
qui pourrait peut-être soulager les
personnels au delà de la question des
lits au delà de la question de
l'orientation des maîtres des patients
et des malades
est-ce qu'il faut augmenter les salaires
est ce qu'on en a les moyens
je pense qu'on en a les moyens mais ces
moyens ils sont peut-être pas illimitée
évidemment moi je crois beaucoup aux
parcours professionnels je crois
beaucoup aussi que la surqualification
des personnels leur professionnalisme
leur courage doit être reconnue et les
diplômes doivent être reconnues pour ça
il ya un effort il faut consentir un
effort
maintenant il faut trouver avec les
moyens financiers qui sont les nôtres
avec l'augmentation qui est la nôtre et
puis je dirais faire les investissements
indispensables pour les nouveaux
équipements parce que comme ça a été dit
la médecine progresse très vite la
médecine ambulatoire progresse également
très vite
c'est un progrès techniques de la
médecine les programmes eu avec cette
idée que la médecine ambulatoire
fonctionne très vite on a aussi fermé
pas mal de liens non on a fait une
rotation peut-être parfois excessives à
l'intérieur des lits ça c'est tout à
fait possible et c'est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve aussi cette rotation
d'aller également dans l'état les épate
vers les établissements
pour personnes âgées je vais vous faire
réagir à un sondage qui a été réalisé il
ya quelques jours par opinionway pour le
quotidien les échos les français qui se
demandent à qui la faute
en matière de crise à l'hôpital sondage
a été fait particulièrement sur la
situation des urgences c'est d'abord
selon eux un manque de moyens financiers
et humains à 52% donc plus de moyens
ce que demandent les français et seuls
8% des sondés didier martin estime que
ces problèmes sont avant tout due à une
mauvaise organisation des hôpitaux alors
là c'est un peu contradictoire est ce
que propose la ministre qui est de
réaliser ce que savent les français
c'est que l'hôpital est au centre du
système de soins ils savent qu'avec leur
carte vitale
voilà la mienne elle va de 2010 n'est
pas récente mais est toujours alité
rocha d'accord avec ça avec une mutuelle
maintenant que dans tout le monde
pouvait à peu près peut bénéficier
on a droit à l'hôpital public à des
soins gratuits et médias de la boad à la
plus grande gravité
et vous allez vous étiez c'est l'hôpital
dans ce sondage les français disent qu'à
une sollicitation des patients pour des
problèmes bénins à 39% c'est un des
soucis de l'hôpital donc il ya vraiment
une idée reçue la tuèrent safina mais
bien sûr mais je vous affirme dit que
c'est une idée reçue mais oui parce que
de toute façon ce qui nécessite pas une
prise en charge
vous savez les hôpitaux sont toujours
quel que soit leur statut qu'ils soient
de proximité ou pas sont toujours les
hôpitaux de proximité pour ceux qui s'y
adresse ch ou pas chu centre hospitalier
de chalon sur saône ou pas lorsque vous
habitez à côté vous vous adressez là où
vous avez votre or les bassins de
population ils sont à côté des gros
hôpitaux donc ça le fait d'avoir des
hôpitaux de proximité va résoudre à
petit poème sur la répartition
territoriale
mais l'engorgement qu'ont rencontré la
difficulté en lit qu'on a aujourd'hui
elles finissent toujours par retomber
sur les autres pour principaux françois
gibault les urgences seront financés en
grande partie par les rejets au
graphique et la population donc on sort
de la logique d'activité mais bien sûr
leur géographie population elle pourra
répondre à ce besoin de proximité
françois thibault vous allez être dans
la rue dans quelques jours devant les
ars les agences régionales de santé
c'est jeudi prochain
qu'est ce que vous allez demander
concrètement agnès buzyn avant qu'elle
qu'elle rende ses conclusions parce
qu'en fait on a l'impression qu'elle
attend de jauger
la mobilisation on va demander déjà
qu'on arrête de faire des jeux de passe
passe et de donner d'une main et
reprendre de l'autre
le haut conseil de pour le financement
de la protection sociale a alerté dès le
début de l'année sur les allègements de
taxes du désagrégement pardon de
cotisations sociales prévues par le
gouvernement qui ne serait pas compensée
qui vont conduire donc à un déficit de 3
4 milliards en 2019 3,6 en 2020 et 5,9
en 2021
donc on le voit bien pour donner
quelques avantages d'un côté c'est dans
une autre poche comprend dans la poche
de ce qu'on appelle nous le salaire
différé puisque ben monsieur martin
disait quand on naît de la plus basse
gravité jusqu'à la plus importante
on est soigné en france et et on peut
l'être parce qu'on a des parce qu'on
cotise pour ça parce qu'il ya des
cotisations derrière donc lorsqu'on fait
ce jeu de passe passe c'est très
compliqué de maintenir les budgets la
cgt au niveau national demande la
suppression de la taxe sur les salaires
qui pèsent actuellement sur les hôpitaux
c'est à dire qu'on prend aujourd'hui sur
le budget de chaque hôpital va % de
taxes à cette envisageable qu'on remet
dans le contre mais dans le budget de
l'état en une en dessous savez il ya jeu
de vases communicants entre le budget de
la santé et ce qui compte c'est aussi
que l'état fonctionne bien et que les
services soient assurés c'est 4 min la
taxe sur les salaires en france vous
avez l'impression que vous attendez-vous
la majorité avec agnès buzyn la
mobilisation de jeudi vous j'ai
confiance
on s'est d'abord vous êtes la
mobilisation de du 14 elle est important
que je sais moi j'espère qu'elle sera
massive pour effectivement poussé dans
le bon sens et après je connais malam
musa
je sais le sens c'est une hospitalière
et je connais très bien tous ces
problèmes là et j'ai ouvert cette
affaire apportera d'autres solutions que
ce qui a été avancé jusqu'à maintenant
merci à tous d'avoir accepté de
participer à cette émission ce matin
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
aujourd'hui dans un instant à point sur
l'actualité régionale puis la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
francis letellier reçoit aurélien pradié
députés les républicains du lot bon
dimanche à tous sur france 3
[Musique]